bonjour je suis Thierry Marx chef de
cuisine et je vais réagir aux archives
de Lina
bonjour Thierry Marx bonjour vous
défendez de nombreuses causes des causes
que nous allons évoquer à travers les
archives on commence par un reportage
d'envoyé spécial où l'on voit que vous
vivez votre passion de manière assez
intense
[Musique]
ah oui
c'était les meilleurs de la gastronomie
ça c'est l'heure on l'attend sur scène
son équipe se tient prête pour la
démonstration
mais Thierry Marx semble tendu concentré
comme pour livrer un combat
il est aujourd'hui l'un des meilleurs
chefs de sa génération deux étoiles
Michelin 19 ennemis sur 20 au Go Emilio
on le consacre on l'applaudit le public
aime ses recettes ludiques dynamiques
son boeuf carotte en rouleau sa quiche
lorraine liquide et ses poires au vin
baignés d'une limonade effervescente
merci beaucoup une cuisine qui raconte
son destin hors du commun
c'est les meilleurs de la gastronomie
c'était c'est intéressant parce que le
New York Times le magazine du Times ça
va être titré
la gastronomie en France et morte
l'innovation est ailleurs donc il était
important pour les chefs de ma
génération d'aller défendre l'idée que
l'innovation était encore bien présente
en France que l'innovation nécessite de
l'audace d'accepter aussi de prendre des
coups d'être critiquer et en même temps
de continuer à déranger des cercles qui
ont été établis par d'autres est-ce que
vous vivez la cuisine comme un combat
non je vis la vie comme un combat je
vais pas reprendre la phrase de
bertolbrest celui qui ne combat pas a
déjà perdu donc en fonction de votre
extraction sociale de votre vie il y a
des combats qui sont amener des combats
qui sont pas au moment des combats
difficiles il faut faire ses choix
comment on devient chef échelle
d'entreprise en ayant en sortant d'une
extraction sociale modeste et d'un
quartier un peu compliqué on est étant
été déscolarisé très tôt donc à un
moment donné il a fallu que je
j'explique pourquoi j'avais fait des
choix de cadre éducationnel qui m'était
propres celles du sport bien sûr mais
celle aussi de l'apprentissage il faut
regarder au dessus de la ligne d'horizon
et comment on peut le faire moi il y a
énormément de gens qui m'ont aidé à
regarder au-dessus de la ligne d'horizon
on va regarder une archive de 1981 sur
une célèbre chaîne de restauration
américaine qui a bouleversé les
habitudes des français
le fast-food une nouvelle façon de se
nourrir à la française avec deux
décennies de retard sur les États-Unis
le hamburger commence à entrer dans les
habitudes alimentaires ou plutôt dans
une façon de vivre le repas familial
n'est plus sacro-saint place maintenant
au repas pratique pourquoi vous venez
manger ici
ça sera peut-être comme ça en général on
n'a pas beaucoup le temps le midi ça va
plus vite
c'est bon chaque jour près de 1000
hamburgers sont ainsi confectionnés
confectionnés stérilisé
c'est le hamburger n'est pas vendu dans
les 10 minutes il est jeté même soir
pour les frites au bout de 7 minutes
[Musique]
c'était une forme de modernité et
finalement on a on a dérégulé notre
alimentation en commençant à se dire
finalement je peux manger tout le temps
et presque n'importe quoi mais on est
arrivé dans du surgras du sur sucre et
quand on regarde ça 40 ans après
finalement on a une une fracture sociale
qui est toujours là très dur et donc une
alimentation individus une alimentation
de gens qui peuvent comprendre ce qu'ils
mangent et avoir un resté à vivre
suffisant pour aller dans autre chose
que cela et puis certains qui rentrent
dans une alimentation hyper
industrialisée et résultat de tout ça
c'est une santé publique qui est très
déséquilibrée aujourd'hui on a une
explosion du diabète de type 2 tous les
médecins confirment on a un marqueur
fort de la de la pauvreté qui est
l'obésité etc donc évidemment il y a une
grande part de responsabilité dans ce
type de restauration on va vous montrer
un des premiers chefs à avoir mis les
légumes dans l'assiette de ces
restaurants c'est Alain Passard
oubliez la viande vive les produits du
potager dès le printemps prochain ce
sera la règle pour un impassar à part
quelques volailles le chef du restaurant
l'Arpège à Paris ne proposera sur sa
carte que des légumes ou des fruits une
première pour un 3 étoiles Michelin
d'abord une décision très personnelle
c'est une relation
effectivement pour moi difficile avec
avec la consommation de la viande donc
je ne mange pratiquement plus de viande
et quelque part c'est aussi une
délivrance et un soulagement par rapport
à un registre où j'avais de plus en plus
de mal à trouver des idées
à l'impassard c'est un modèle il a eu
raison avant tout le monde on est en
pleine crise de la vache folle dans ces
images à mon avis et il comprend qu'il y
a un virage à prendre il faut beaucoup
d'audace il a trois étoiles c'est un
chef extrêmement créatif et sa
créativité c'est basé sur le fait qu'il
choisit l'option du modèle végétarien
avec son propre potager alors ça a été
beaucoup copié même maintenant il faut
il faut le dire il a inspiré énormément
de de chef dans ce domaine mais
aujourd'hui on a un énorme stress sur
cette planète ce qui est le stress
hydrique donc on s'est dit la
gastronomie a un problème oui ça va être
le stress hydrique 2050 2070 il se
trouve que le stress hydrique on y est
maintenant donc il faut moins de
protéines animales pour augmenter la
protéine végétale donc il y a un vrai
une vraie anticipation chez Alain
Bassard est-ce que la souffrance animale
c'est une cause qui vous importe aussi
la souffrance animale me gêne beaucoup
quand je vois des élevages intensifs ça
me dérange qu'on fasse encore en France
ce type d'élevage je vois en Chine des
élevages à étages c'est absolument
impensable de de considérer qu'on peut
manger de la protéine dans ces
conditions-là moi je pense qu'on devrait
rentrer dans l'aspect flexitérien de
notre alimentation c'est de dire bon on
va passer du bœuf carotte au carottes
bœuf vous voyez 80 vins 80% végétal 20%
protéines animales allez 40 g de viande
ou 80 g de viande une fois par semaine
ça suffit largement je pense que les
gens qui aiment la protéine
retrouveraient le bonheur de la protéine
animale de qualité et puis ça quand même
améliorerait considérablement l'impact
l'impact que peut avoir les élevages et
notamment les élevages intensifs sur
l'impact environnemental il n'y a pas si
longtemps les femmes étaient exclues des
fourneaux des grands restaurants en 1975
le célèbre chroniqueur Christian Guy
expliqué pourquoi
est-ce que les femmes ont du talent en
cuisine
certainement pas voyons enfin ça serait
on les verrait avoir inventé un plat on
verrait un Bocuse femme on verrait
quelque chose comme ça la meilleure
preuve puisque vous parlez de féminin
chef n'a pas de féminin vous allez dire
une chef scheffen
de l'étoile d'ordre vous aurez bonne
nuit
elles ont tellement fait la cuisine dans
leur vie les femmes que leur ambition ne
se situent pas là
elle pourrait quand même continuer à le
faire ce serait quand même très agréable
mais le fond elle le réussissent mal non
mais attends est-ce que vous contestez
c'est l'esprit créateur de la femme
la femme a peut-être trop d'imagination
lorsqu'elle fait un plat parce que de
faire un grand plat et ben elle ne suit
pas la recette classique alors on ne
sait pas du tout ce que ça va donner bon
allez et ça c'est terrible en cuisine
une femme ne réussit jamais deux fois le
même plaque ça c'est pas possible non ça
c'est c'est pas entendable je veux dire
que on a vu arriver les femmes avec
bonheur dans la cuisine même à l'époque
de ce monsieur faut pas oublier qu'il y
avait eu la mer brasier il y avait pas
mal de femmes qui se sont imposées en
cuisine et qui ont fait l'écriture de la
cuisine française
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment plus haut
possible d'entendre ça il y a des chefs
femme qui arrive dans nos métiers qui
sont des femmes absolument créatives
organisées
on voit Hélène darrozla mais il y a
Anne-Sophie Pic il y a une ambiance de
femme aujourd'hui qui sont à la tête de
nos brigades et qui font
merveilleusement bien et qui ont un
esprit créatif ça a une brigade que ce
soit un homme ou une femme c'est
l'exemple qui fait la preuve de
l'autorité dès lors que vous montrez
l'exemple et bien finalement l'équipe se
rassemblent derrière vous que ce soit
une femme ou un homme mais deux premiers
sous chefs étaient des sous-chefs femmes
et elles sont devenues chez aujourd'hui
elles sont chef étoilé donc il y a aucun
le ce monsieur est un peu
décalé je trouve même à son époque
d'ailleurs c'est vrai que le monde des
cuisines n'est pas tendre depuis
quelques années ni pour les femmes ni
pour les hommes on écoute des
témoignages qui révèlent ce qui s'y
passe on est en 2015 le but du jeu de
toute façon ou la senti tout de suite
c'était c'était de nous briser briser
moralement je fais aussi toujours des
cauchemars
qui font très mal sur le moment et qui
laissent des traces
face au scandale la plupart des chefs
français se serrent les coudes rares
sont ceux qui acceptent de parler
ouvertement des violences j'avais passé
un mec par le passe comme ça je l'avais
pris par la cravate avec son gilet et
j'avais tellement tiré que le mec il est
passé par le Pass comment font les
cuisiniers pour résister à temps de
pression
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu des abus dans ce
métier il y a eu des gens qui se sont
comportés de façon navante mais en même
temps certains chefs
ne mesurais pas
considérer que ce qu'ils avaient vécu
était normal donc ils allaient
reproduire cela et puis il ne contrôle
pas non plus le deuxième et le troisième
tiers qui sous prétexte que le chef
aurait dit imposait des conditions de
travail à des jeunes gens qui n'étaient
pas admissibles tout ça c'est largement
dénoncé moi en tant que président de
l'uni je soutiens tous les jeunes gens
qui viennent nous voir en nous disant
j'ai été maltraité on va tenter on va
déposer une plainte et ça et bien on les
accompagne pour les aider à dénoncer ce
type de de propos donc on est très clair
avec ça aujourd'hui on devrait
considérer que la formation managériale
de ces futurs chefs à l'école hôtelière
ou même dans des CFA ou des lycées
professionnels devraient faire partie de
la formation et y compris une reprise en
main de la condition physique et du
sport parce que rien de mieux que le
sport pour vous faudra mettre du temps
entre l'émotion et l'action et ça ça me
paraît être essentiel de reformer des
managers ou de continuer à former ces
futures managers en entreprise et
vous-même vous en avez subi des
violences
et exercer ça vous est arrivé non ça
m'est arrivé d'être très tendu vis-à-vis
de d'une erreur qui venait faite surtout
au début de ma carrière c'était vraiment
des tensions énormes on cherchait
vraiment à avoir une reconnaissance
professionnelle moi je sortais un petit
peu de nulle part j'étais un peu rentré
par effraction dans ce métier donc il y
a eu des tensions très très vif mais
jamais de bagarre générale dans la
cuisine on dit vous chuchotez en cuisine
est-ce que c'est vrai oui je chuchote
parce que je n'aime pas le bruit je
n'aime pas le cette nuisance du bruit ce
côté très toxique du bruit donc je
chuchote comme ça tout le monde fait
attention à baisser la voix et quand un
ordre des données parce que c'est un
ordre est une ponctuation finalement du
moment de travail et bien comme ça tout
le monde a entendu tout le monde reste
concentré et ça m'évite de mettre une
pression excessive sur les
collaborateurs et j'ai essayé
d'enseigner ça mais à mes jeunes
collaborateurs qui aujourd'hui
globalement font la même chose c'est
vrai que la cuisine pour vous c'est une
question de transmission elle vous a
mené jusqu'en prison où vous avez donné
des cours de cuisine nous allons à la
centrale de Poissy ici les couteaux sont
sous haute surveillance comme les
détenus tous condamnés à de longues
peines à Poissy peu de formation pour
beaucoup de détenus cela ont dû prouver
leur motivation pour intégrer cette
formation de cuisine très courue
parce qu'il donne de son temps et
qui fait des concessions pour venir nous
voir et c'est pas tout le monde qu'il
fait aussi quoi l'an dernier tous les
détenus du groupe ont décroché leur bac
professionnel même si la vocation n'est
pas toujours au rendez-vous
c'est intéressant de montrer les actions
que nous pouvons mener en détention
j'entends les critiques très souvent
pourquoi s'occuper de ces gens-là
et la réponse elle est simple c'est à
dire que si vous considérez qu'on doit
vivre tous dans une démocratie alors
dans une démocratie les gens rentrent en
prison et en sorte et donc il faut qu'il
en sorte avec un projet positif et dans
une recette il y a un programme
pédagogique la rythmétique la grammaire
le français le français lui écrit par
les une ouverture d'esprit une
connaissance de l'histoire-géographie
quand vous faites un filet de bœuf
Wellington très rapidement vous êtes
amené à parler de Wellington de Waterloo
de Bonaparte de la Révolution française
vous ouvrez à la curiosité et souvent
c'est ce que je dis aussi à mes jeunes
collaborateurs quand on parle de
transmission je leur dis c'est pas votre
employeur qui protège votre emploi c'est
votre curiosité plus vous allez être
curieux plus vous allez devenir des
hommes libres c'est la même chose que je
transmets en détention un jour indétenu
m'a répondu il me dit vous savez quand
vous venez je me lève parce que depuis
que je suis en détention je suis même
plus obligé de me lever de mon lit quand
je sais que vous venez dans la semaine
où vous venez je reprends mes cahiers de
cours je me lève je me change
et je viens en tenue pour le cours ça
c'est déjà important c'est une remise en
forme et en verticalité vers un projet
politique on va vous montrer maintenant
un moment difficile de l'histoire de la
cuisine le suicide de Bernard Loiseau
malgré le drame le restaurant La Côte
d'Or a ouvert ses portes aujourd'hui
Bernard Loiseau avait repris cette
maison sur le déclin il y a 28 ans à
force de travail et de talent il en a
fait un bastion de la gastronomie
française
tous ces gens tous ces êtres
exceptionnels qui vous donnent tant une
impression de temps d'assurance ils ont
tous une très forte fragilité ils ont
tous des moments de doute tellement fort
et là il a eu un doute tellement fort et
malheureusement il s'est retrouvé seul
durant quelques heures et on sait pas ce
qui s'est passé dans sa tête j'étais
apprenti chez trois gros dans les années
68 71 et puis donc j'avais le visage des
frappes trois gros tu es de mon lit puis
j'ai dit un jour je serais comme eux et
puis tous les jours vous voyez je me
lève je mets mes chaussettes et puis je
dis un but trois étoiles Michelin trois
étoiles au Michelin un rêve qui se
réalise en 1991 après une décennie
d'excellence cette année Bernard Loiseau
venait de voir sa note rétrogradée au
goût et mio passant de 19 à 17 sur 20 je
voulais travailler en cuisine et donc je
suis allé me présenter chez Bernard
Loiseau évidemment j'avais pas de CV pas
de certificat de travail j'avais un
passé un cap en 6 mois
et c'était un homme lumineux mais
lumineux c'est à dire que c'est un homme
qui respirait la gastronomie qui
respirait la transmission c'est un homme
qui donnait envie quand il ne m'a pas
embauché finalement il me dit mais tu
déjeunes ici je dis non mais j'ai pas
les moyens d'un trois étoiles il me dit
non mais tu déjeunes si je t'invite
qu'il a mis une table devant la porte et
il nous a fait déjeuner à ce moment là
et il m'a donné une telle énergie il
était tellement solaire
tellement riche de générosité que je
suis à l'imprésenter dans deux
restaurants à Paris un qui s'appelait La
Marée j'ai pas été pris et ensuite j'ai
été présenté chez taevan et j'ai dit
quand le chef Claude de ligne m'a
demandé d'où je venais je dis j'arrive
de chez Bernard Loiseau mais j'ai pas
dit que Bernard m'avait invité qui a
déjeuner mais cette générosité là m'a
permis d'ouvrir la porte de chez
Thaïlande votre cuisine et le reflet de
votre vie on vous amène à Bois l'Abbé
dans la cité de votre enfance
déjà il fait froid
et il y avait plein de terre partout il
y avait pas le gazon devant ou c'est
qu'on est là il y avait il y a pas tout
ça j'ai dit bon bah l'été ça se trouve
c'est plus joli moi ça m'a paru bien
donc j'étais avant il y avait pas de
confort j'habitais un sixième et
il y avait pas de chauffage il y avait
pas de salle de bain
et puis j'avais une pièce en moi quand
même
on définitive c'est important entre
s'ennuyer peut-être un peu et puis la
douche et chauffage vous avez quand même
choisi non j'ai choisi parce que ici ça
m'a plu il y a eu il y avait un grand
balcon et que j'avais pas là-bas
confort les pièces étaient plus grandes
la salle de bain tout ça c'est
très important pour pour les enfants
surtout
au fond Paris ou enfin une grande ville
ça vous manque oui
moi j'aime mieux Paris
et du béton dessus c'est exactement les
images que vous voyez là nos parents
l'ont cru on a cru que
on a cru que c'était un nouvel eldorado
qui aurait du travail qui aurait plein
de choses et puis l'ambiance c'est
rapidement dégradée parce que déjà
beaucoup d'adultes avaient perdu leurs
emplois et finalement se replié dans les
cages d'escalier il y avait rien d'autre
à faire pour aller rien qu'à
Joinville-le-Pont il y avait cinq bus à
prendre
et
une chance peut-être dans ces quartiers
à l'époque c'est que globalement c'était
des
banlieues rouges comme on dit des
banlieues communistes et le sport était
gratuit pour beaucoup de mes copains le
sport a été après la déscolarisation un
lieu de
un nouveau cadre éducationnel ça ça a
été fort mais la dégradation de ces
quartiers est arrivée très très vite
d'ailleurs nos parents n'avaient de
cesse qu'elle essayait de trouver le
moindre denier pour essayer de quitter
ça et d'aller très très loin de ce béton
tout était toujours en panne toute
venait toujours très sale et tous ces
gens qui garçons et petites filles que
vous voyez là ça a pas durer très
longtemps on est devenu très rapidement
des adolescents très rapidement on ne
pouvait plus jouer dans les cours donc
ces quartiers sont devenus surplillés
sur eux-mêmes c'est devenu des silos
j'ai quitté ces quartiers sans tourner
la tête vraiment je suis parti j'ai
jamais voulu y revenir et
quelques années maintenant après je suis
revenu on a créé des écoles dans ces
quartiers et on s'aperçut que évidemment
toute le tous les petits trafics qui
sont devenus des gros trafics vous savez
dans ces quartiers ce qu'on leur marque
depuis 10 ans c'est que vous avez trois
grands moteurs d'inclusion l'art
l'artisanat et le sport pourquoi parce
que vous êtes dans le fer pour apprendre
bien souvent beaucoup de jeunes gens
dans ces quartiers ont détesté l'école
mais ils redécouvre dans l'art
l'artisanat et le sport le fer pour
apprendre et là ça les remotive et bien
souvent on arrive à leur trouver des
projets des projets formidables parce
que s'il y a bien une chose qu'on a
appris dans ces quartiers c'est
l'adaptabilité vous pratiquez le judo
d'autres arts martiaux comme le MMA
c'est l'heure de regarder une archive
qui parle de méditation de moine et de
samouraï
pour le mettre sousara l'un des
supérieurs du grand temple zen n'gakuji
le tir à l'arc la méditation et la vie
intérieure ne sont jamais séparés
autrefois il n'était pas rare que la fin
de leur vie de grands samouraïs
deviennent moins de Zen
comment expliquer que tel homme capable
de couper en deux un adversaire en une
fraction de seconde adopte une
spiritualité qui est par essence non
violente
c'est sans doute parce que les arts
martiaux et façons la peur
créé au-delà de la violence maîtrisée
une conscience plus vaste de la paix
intérieure
c'est très juste le propos est très
juste d'ailleurs au Japon on dit souvent
quand on pratique l'escrime au sabre on
dit KENZEN
ichinio ça après méditation ne fait
qu'un et ce qui vous permet de mettre du
temps entre votre émotion et vos actions
et la méditation le fait de vous
recentrer sur vous-même vous permet
justement de mettre du temps entre
l'émotion et l'action et ça c'est
c'était essentiel et vous avez évoqué
l'esprit des samouraïs samouraï n'avait
pas peur de la mort il avait peur de mal
remplir les jours entre leur vie et leur
mort c'est totalement différent et c'est
tout ce qui fait l'intérêt de l'art
martial qui est vraiment pas une
succession de coup de pied de coup de
poing comme on pourrait le croire ou de
d'être plus fort mais de savoir être en
capacité de se recentrer de se retrouver
soi-même il y a vraiment une discipline
qu'il faut
qu'il faut il faut se donner c'est la
même chose que la cuisine finalement
c'est rigueur c'est votre verticalité
engagement faut y aller à un moment
donné il va falloir vous confronter et
régularité régularité de vous entraîner
régulièrement et alors vous vous êtes
plutôt moi nous samouraï plutôt moine
nous allons vous demander de choisir la
personne qui va vous poser la prochaine
question entre Henri Chapier Caroline
Tresca Laura de l'heure et Jacques
Chancel
Henri Chapier
parce que je connais Caroline Tresca
j'aime beaucoup
Laure Adler aussi
Henri Chapier j'ai jamais eu l'occasion
de j'ai croisé sa voix comme tout à
chacun mais j'ai jamais c'est jamais une
personnalité que j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer
avez-vous
détournement ou plutôt disons des
préoccupations
métaphysiques des croyances profondes et
un peu caché bien sûr ça c'est alpas je
crois à l'observation de la nature
vraiment je pense que la nature a encore
beaucoup de leçons à nous donner et
l'observation du biomimétisme par
exemple et pendant ces périodes de
méditation pour moi c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel et qui m'apporte beaucoup la
vie qu'on voit et la vie qu'on ne voit
pas et je pense que en observant la
nature c'est la nature qui m'a appris
finalement à accepter la vie telle
qu'elle est parce que avec ces cycles
avec ces régénérescences et puis cette
idée de la disparition qui finalement
n'est pas une disparition définitive
mais qui devient un compost pour de
nouveau enrichir la vie et ça je crois
que si on a un bon karma on peut le
réussir
[Musique]